über viele dinge lässt sich streiten
aber nicht darüber dass der klimawandel
real und vor allem größtenteils
menschengemacht ist
warum regnet es wohl den letzten tagen
und wochen so oft und zwar in strömen
ganz ehrlich ich verstehe die zweifel
nicht fakt ist unser planet heißt sich
auch und ja das ist in der erdgeschichte
schon häufiger passiert aber das war
nicht unbedingt angenehm damals
allerdings nicht in dem tempo der
vergangenen 200 jahre schuld daran ist
ganz alleine der mensch und warum an
dieser stelle kein platz für skeptiker
ist jetzt endlich zum salzen sitzen herz
bekommen ich habe mal wieder einen etwas
provozierenden titel genommen der
einfach klar machen soll wie die lage
ist es gibt einfach keinen absolut
keinen wissenschaftlichen zweifel am
menschen gemachten klimawandel die
fachwelt ist sich einig das klima auf
der erde hat sich im laufe ihrer
geschichte immer mal wieder verändert es
galten und die wechselt mit warmzeiten
ab die ursachen dafür waren natürliche
art doch tief ist jetzt anders
der treibhauseffekt ist menschengemacht
und trägt zum klimawandel entscheidend
bei und doch gibt es und wir werden
leider nicht leiser obwohl sie doch
inhaltlich genau null zur diskussion
beisteuern die skeptiker und zweifel
natürlich in zwei forscherinnen und
forscher zu sein
das bedeutet auch theorien und belege
immer und immer wieder zu hinterfragen
sitzung falsifizieren oder verifizieren
wie es dort heißt die chance dabei
unsere erkenntnisse und prognosen zu
verfeinern und verlässlicher zu machen
ich brenne total für das thema und ich
freue mich umso mehr darüber dass einer
von euch wer scholar nämlich dieses
video hier vorgeschlagen hat an dieser
stelle ein riesen dankeschön
mit diesem video will ich euch alle
dinge mit auf den weg geben wir wissen
muss um auch die letzten zweifler und
skeptiker an die wand zu diskutieren
weil das es wirklich nötig schließlich
liegt es in unserer hand die notbremse
zu ziehen um den klimawandel und seine
weitreichenden konsequenzen zu stoppen
oder zumindest zu verlangsamen mein
motto mit fakten gegen jeden zweifel zu
ergänzen hieß es gegen die überzeugung
solche menschen wie dem amerikanischen
präsidenten donald trump der aus dem
pariser klimaabkommen aussteigt und wer
den klimawandel als eine erfindung der
chinesen bezeichnet wobei gerade amerika
besonders unter den folgen leidet es
paradox ist darf nicht dabei bleiben
darüber den kopf zu schütteln und
weiterzumachen wie bisher denn gerade
weil der klimawandel menschengemacht ist
kann er auch von uns menschen gestoppt
werden also los geht's jetzt mit den
vier fakten zum klimawandel gegen jeden
zweifel erster fakt der treibhauseffekt
ist er wie seit 120 jahren
wir wissen alle menschen brauchen in
fast allem was sie tun energie fabriken
maschinen autos handys und so weiter so
verbrauchen strom dessen energie meist
durch verbrennung von öl gas oder kohle
erzeugt mit treibhausgase die dabei
entstehen etwa kohlendioxid erwärmen die
atmosphäre
denn je mehr davon in der atmosphäre
enthalten ist umso weniger
sonnenstrahlung kann als infrarot
strahlung zurück ins all reflektiert
werden diesen mechanismus kennen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dank diverser experimente und
beobachtung weit ganzen 120 jahren
zusätzlich soll menschen dafür dass es
immer weniger waldflächen gibt in denen
das co2 gespeichert werden könnte auch
unser maßloser fleischkonsum heitz die
erde auf den rinder und schweine pusten
mengen an methan in die luft seit 850
gibt es verlässliche daten zur globalen
mitteltemperatur ihrem s kurve zeigt
einen weltweiten anstieg um 0,8 grad ein
langfristiger aufwärtstrend als sie das
tempo aller bisherigen veränderungen
übersteigt so der aktuelle
wissenschaftliche konsens an dieser
stelle möchte ich ins bett gegangen
direkt den wind aus den segeln nehmen
und auch das argument eingehen
das kohlendioxid folge und nicht ursache
des klimawandels als beispiel wird der
rasante anstieg von co2 in der
atmosphäre vor etwa 55 millionen jahren
genannt dabei außer acht gelassen wird
die veränderung damals passierten
innerhalb von etwa 10.000 jahren von
wegner sein und nicht wie der aktuelle
klimawandel innerhalb von wenigen
jahrhunderten um es noch mal klipp und
klar auf den punkt es gibt zahlreiche
belege dafür dass die verbrennung von
kohle und öl zu den krassen co2 anstieg
geführt hat den wir heute erleben
zahlreiche verschiedene messungen zeigen
zudem schwarz auf weiß dass die co2
konzentration aktuell so hoch ist wie
noch niemals zuvor in den achtung
letzten 800.000 jahren in denen es aus
verschiedenen natürlichen gründen
deutliche klimaveränderungen gab
wohlgemerkt weiter fakt dass pohl 1
misst und der meeresspiegel steigt an
wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist dass ein
großteil der gletscher an masse verliert
dauer ford gebiete fangen an zu schauen
und das festland eis in grönland
schritten all das lässt den
meeresspiegel ansteigen und gibt keine
forscher oder forscherin die das
ernsthaft bezweifeln würden fotos aus
dem all zeigen dass das meer im hohen
norden an stellen die sonst zu
befreunden zuletzt offen geblieben ist
der zusammenhang zwischen dem schwund
des meeres eises und der globalen
erwärmung ist logisch und gesichert
diskutiert wird nur noch wie lange es
dauert bis die riesigen eismassen
instabil werden es gibt jedoch viele
studien die darauf deuten dass das tor
nicht mehr zu stoppen ist und ja es gibt
weiterhin diskurs darüber in welchem
ausmaß der anstieg des meeresspiegels
stattfinden wird doch diesmal wird
darauf dass jemand zuverlässig
voraussagen kannst wo das meer an wasser
durch wind und meeresströmungen hin
getrieben wird und wie genau sich der
verlust von gletschern in der antarktis
und grönland entwickelt wird und ja
dabei ist bedacht das meereseis den
wasserspiegel nicht steigen lässt ein an
land aber wer wohl schwinden des meeres
sorgt aber dafür dass zum beispiel ein
zum einen weniger sonnenlicht ins all
reflektiert wird und es deshalb wärmer
wird und das meerwasser verdunstet und
jetzt zum beispiel bei uns deutlich
stärker regnet größer packt die
klimageschichte der erde ist konserviert
und somit messbar weil dem ist die erde
gibt hat sich ihr klima immer mal wieder
verändert und das ist keine vermutung
der vorsorgende forscher sondern eine
messe und korallenriffe 1 versteinerten
baumringe oder der meeresgrund haben die
klimageschichte des planeten in sich
konserviert ihre chemische analyse zeigt
wie viel kohlendioxid zu welchem
zeitpunkt in der luft wie die
luftfeuchtigkeit war und eben auch
welche partikel zu welcher zeit in der
atmosphäre schwebten doch nicht nur die
klimageschichte ist etwa auch der
aktuelle zustand ist messbar zum
beispiel mit hilfe von satelliten seit
1958 übrigen wird der co2 gehalt der
atmosphäre täglich gemessen auf dem
vulkan mauna loa in arbeit
seitdem ist er von 320 auf mehr als 400
familien also teilchen pro million teil
gestiegen ähnlich wie der gehalt des
zweitwichtigsten treibhausgases methan
das heißt die menge ist knapp 30 prozent
gestiegen und dass der anteil an der
luftwege ring ist das hat überhaupt
nichts über die wirkung aus diese
messergebnisse lassen nur einen schluss
zu die aktuelle globale erwärmung ist
zum größten teil menschen gemacht nur
etwa ein zehntel der heutigen
erderwärmung lässt sich momentan auch
die wirrnis rollen können welche
einzelne staaten dagegen konkret für den
meisten ausstoß von treibhausgasen
verantwortlich sind dass es damit nicht
nachzuvollziehen wenn die gase verteilen
die innerhalb weniger wochen gleichmäßig
um den globus herum
dieser fakt klima skeptiker sind und
eine eigene plausible erklärung schuldig
wir jetzt mitbekommen habt sind
unzählige vorstand seit jahren
unermüdlich dabei den klima zustand der
erde zu ermitteln unwahrscheinlich also
dass die fundamentale aspekte übersehen
haben im gegenteil wenn man alle als
seriös einzustufen studien zusammen
ergibt sich ein mehr als
übereinstimmendes bild der klimawandel
ist real und menschengemacht jetzt
kommen die klimaskeptiker mit fehlern
aus der vergangenheit die sie uns unter
die nase reiben und tatsächlich wurden
fehler gemacht das ist auch nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich
bei tausenden wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen beispiel
climategate im jahr 2009 kurz vor dem
klimagipfel hatten hacker mails
öffentlich gemacht die zeigen sollten
dass die globale erwärmung eine
verschwörungstheorie sei absoluter
quatsch
hier ging es um grabenkämpfe zwischen
wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen mit gefälschten
forschungsarbeiten oder ähnlichem hatte
das rein gar nichts zu tun
außerdem gelitten hat die
glaubwürdigkeit der user klima
forscherinnen und forscher an der
sogenannten hockeyschläger kurve die in
ihrer ersten fassung von vor 20 jahren
tatsächlich statistische schwächen
aufwies will man ganz normal in der
forschung dass eine theorie immer weiter
verfeinert wird und die überarbeitung
der verfassung zeit genau wie viele
andere berechnungen modelle dass es
keinen grund gibt die grundaussage der
klimaforschung anzuzweifeln es ist eben
normal in der wissenschaft forschung
immer wieder zu überprüfen und zu
korrigieren nur in der klimaforschung
ist das inzwischen so aufgestellt dass
es keinen ernstzunehmenden zweifel mehr
gibt und so arbeiten wie nicht
anzunehmen skeptisch man stelle
beispielsweise irgendeine theorie auf
die anderen kram passt dann sucht man
sich dazu ganz einfach eine bereits
existierende zeitreihe mit daten raus
und wähle den ausgangspunkt ganz
geschickt so aus dass er als beweis
grundlage braucht irgendein aus mit der
die eigene theorie stützt ihn findet man
immer mit dieser rosinenpickerei
attackieren klima skeptiker aber immer
nur einzelne punkt ohne auch nur einmal
ansatzweise selbst einen schlüssigen
erklärungsansatz aufzustellen können sie
auch nicht es ist ja unwissenschaftlich
das ist nämlich ein ziemlich wichtiger
punkt die skeptiker haben gar keine
eigenen theorien warum wird es so heil
woher kommt der anstieg und warum sollen
die vernichtung der wälder und die
produktion vom klima sagen muss zum
klimawandels würden nun befragt und
diesen laien und fachfremden
wissenschaftlern gegenübersteht
annähernd die ganze welt der
wissenschaft keine ernst zu nehmende
fachgesellschaft keine ernst zu nehmende
forschungsorganisationen bezweifelt auch
nur im geringsten dass der klimawandel
ein durch menschliches handeln
verursachter fakt ist wenn ihr kein
video mehr zum klimawandel verpassen
wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es bei sagen hier mit
evolutionstheorie endgültig bestätigt
kreationisten auf verlorenem posten ein
ähnliches video zu einem ganz anderen
thema ein klick und es läuft los und
ansonsten bis dann klettern